اعادت السلطات التونسيه اعتقال رئيس
الحكومه التونسيه الاسبق حماد الجبالي
يتزامن ذلك ودعوه هيئه الدفاع عن
المعتقلين السياسيين للافراج عنهم بعد
استفاهم المده القصوى للايقاف التحفظي كان
هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات ما خلفيات اعتقال شخصيات سياسيه
بارزه وقيادات حكوميه سابقه في الدوله كيف
نقرا السياق العام الذي جاءت فيها هذه
العط قالت ما افاق الخروج من الازمه
السياسيه التي تشهدها البلاد منذ
الاجراءات
الاستثنائيه كل مطلع على الحد الادنى من
الوضع القانوني والسياسي بتونس وعلى هذه
الملفات يرى بوضوح انها ملفات سياسيه بشكل
مطلق وانها ملفات مفتعله الهدف الوحيد
منها
هو محاصره المعارضه ومحاصر الحياه
السياسيه وليس هناك اي وقائع ماديه وليس
هناك اي محجوز وليس هناك اي شيء يمكن ان
يوفر الحد الادنى من مواجهه التتبع بخصوص
الاحالات وما شملته من اشخاص مختلفين من
حيث التوجهات السياسيه ومن
حيث القيمه والوزن السياسي بدليل ان هناك
صحفيين وهناك رجال اعمال وهناك امنيين من
اعلى طراز واعلى القيادات الامنيه تم
ايقافها ولا علاقه لها لا بالسياسه ولا
بالاعمال ولا بالمال وهذا دليل قاطع ثاني
على توازن التوجه السياسي والقضائي في
تونس والذي يتطابق معايير الامم المتحده
اذا كنا نبحث عن دوله قانون ومؤسسات
واستقرار سياسي وقضائي والايمان بالقضاء
فلنبتعد قليلا عن موضوع التدويل وموضوع
رمي الكره الى انها تلك القضايا هي قضايا
ذات طابع سياسي كل الوثائق تم افتعالها
وتم تجمعها من هواتفهم وهي كلها حوارات
سياسيه ليس هناك اي وثيقه ترتبط بالتهم
الضخمه والخطيره والمخيفه التي وجهت لهم
ليس هناك ما يبحث فيه في الملف نحن نميز
نحن نتعامل مع هذه الملفات سواء ملفات
الحق العام او الملفات السياسيه هناك
قواعد القانون الجزائي وهناك قواعد البحث
وهناك قواعد للتحقيق اي محامي غير تونسي
عندما يطلع على هذا الملف اذا اتيح
الاحتكام الى اي رجل قانون في العالم
سيصرح بشكل مباشر انه هذه الملفات لا
تستحق حتى فتح
عندما تعتقل المحامين عندما تعتقل
الصحفيين عندما تعتقل رجال صنع الراي
العام ستخف المجتمع ليس هناك اي استبداد
في العالم لا يتجه الى هذا الاسلوب
المعارضه لها كامل الحق في ان تعارض وهذا
امر محسوم في كافه الديمقراطيات في العالم
لان المعارضه ان تتجه الى كسر العظام
المعركه معركه سياسيه بامتياز من منذ
قرابه السبعه او ثمانيه اشهر احتد الصدام
بين السلطه والمعارضه وقلنا عديد المرات
ان المعارضه ان تتجنب هذا الصدام الحاد
جدا جدا المعركه الان بقدر ما هي سياسيه
بقدر ما انه القضاء يقوم بواجبه على كامل
وجه في اطار العداله وكفاله العداله
التامه والحياد لا لا السلطه تختار من بين
معارضيها من تعتقد لانهم يمثلون خطرا
سياسيا فقط عليها وتوجه رسائلها من خلالهم
المشكله الرئيسيه في تونس قبل ان تكون
حقوقيه وقبل ان تكون اجرائيه هي مشكله
سياسيه بدون شك ان المعارضه التونسيه
تعاني من امراض عديده منها ما ذكرت سيادتك
انت ومنها ما هو اكثر وهي علاقه المعارضه
بالجمهور ليست قادره ولا تقدم عرض سياسي
جذاب للجمهور التونسي وهذا احد ازمات ولكن
هذا لا يبرر بقاء البلاد في حاله حكم فردي
بشكل مطلق هناك ازمه كبيره بين مراكز
القوه ومراكز الضغط السياسي المعارضه تريد
تصدير المعركه السياسيه الى المنظمات
الدوليه ليس اكثر ولا
اقل
اساسا من يمتلك 99 من الاوراق حاليا هو
رئيس الدوله هو الذي يحتكر الحياه
السياسيه هو الذي يمسك بكل شيء هو الذي
يمكنه ان يوجه البلاد نحو حاله من الحوار
ومن المراجعات الشامله التي تقوم بها كل
الاطراف ويمكنها ان تبني وطنا مشتركا
تتقاسم فيه الاعباء وتنتقل به من حاله
الضعف وحاله الانذار الموجوده الى حاله
متقدمه عندنا السلطه سياسيه مصره على
احتكار الحياه السياسيه بشكل مطلق وعلى
توجيه التهم لمعارضيه السياسيين وعلى
تبرير الوضع الاقتصادي بشعارات من قبيل
الاحتكار لا يمكن لهذه البلاد ان تتقدم
بهذا الطريق الانفرادي في التفكير وبدون
تقديم اي حل في اي
مجال